it doesn't really matter what the
intentions were
discussion on whether or not we should
have a referendum on this treaty that's
not relevant it's not relevant what is
relevant is there more than 400,000
people said that we should have a
referendum on this treaty that is the
only thing that is relevant and what is
next to that relevant on april sixth is
the question that's being asked to to
the judge electorate and that question
is do you are you i'm in favor or
against an association treaty between
the EU and ukraine that's the only thing
that's relevant and that's the only
thing that is in the legal sense
relevant because the law defined that
there should be a referendum and that
this should be the question I'm not even
interested in their opinions of these
three people I'm not interested in their
opinions I'm interested in your opinion
and that of the voters of the
Netherlands okay and they will decide
what will happen april six but the
answer then he'll talking about legal
positions now as we are you know coming
close to the referendum all kind of
legal scholars experts today in the
Financial Times only eight o'clock news
a scholar from a lady university of
improvements explained that the impact
of snow fog if it will be enough out
will be not that much because the
economic part of the treaty is already
the exclusive competence of the EU so
you know essentially it's a little bit
much ado about nothing which will cost
us 30 million euros much ado about
nothing trade I'm not against trade I'm
not even against free trade ladies and
gentlemen I I might be critical I might
be critical about the neoliberal context
of this treaty but that's a different
debate the trade agreement is not what
people object to is my conviction I
think that people fear the political
part of this agreement and the political
part is about foreign policy is about
security policy is about defense and
other issues that should not be in a
trade agreement he
is a trade agreement with Morocco it's
14 pages 96 articles all about trade
nothing about security nothing about
defense nothing about the the way that
the economy should be organized this is
in many aspects it looks more like
stabilisation and association agreement
that we have with countries on the
Balkans ok can you then and then we'll
open the floor to the others explain why
according to you your party it will be
good for the Ukraine not to have this
association clear the problem in the
Ukraine in Ukraine right now is
instability instability internally
people are killing each other about
10,000 people dead in an internal
conflict there is a next ternal problem
with Russia um cream is already lost for
Ukraine Dom bars we don't know what the
future is we should help Ukraine to
become a stable country now if we if we
have a treaty that brings Ukraine fully
into the European influence fear
including aspects of security defense
and foreign policy then maybe a majority
in Ukraine will feel at ease at home in
this and in this European sphere but a
part of Ukraine will not and therefore
the conflict that is now killing people
will not be solved the Minsk agreements
will not be delivered as they are not
delivered today and that will lead
eventually to deepening and lengthening
of the conflict it will lead to a
partition of the country and that is not
only very bad for Ukraine it's also very
dangerous for other countries in the
region look at mall of our interest next
year look in the end we should even fear
that it might have an influence on the
Baltic States so it is not good for the
people living in Ukraine and the
instability will lead to very dangerous
situation situations in the pair of free
now you must be touched because we are
not only bringing you flowers and tulips
but also piece right look it is great to
have such a great crowd interested in
what will be cannon next week I am
probably probably the only person here
who read the whole agreement because I
was chief negotiator for the agreement
for five years so I don't have a text of
the agreement in front of me I know it
by heart really by fat and for me it's
not also in only the political point for
me it's also personal conviction but at
the same time it's also personal
conviction for seventy-five percent of
Ukrainians that the way of their she
asian agreement it's a way of reforms in
Ukraine and because of that what we have
in this agreement is there how to make
Ukraine European country in the sense of
our reforms in the sense of democracy
because we had pro-russian regime we
destroy democracy in Ukraine which is
without about rule of law which
destroyed yeah exactly but you know I I
had been fighting with that and i will
also in the future and my personal
choice is to live in a free country
because this agreement is about
democracy freedom and rule of law and
one sitting in the Normandy format
because mr. van Bommel just mentioned it
we were talking with our German and
French colleague and mr. Lavrov and he
told me look I report just for one
person in Russia to the Russian
President Putin
and I said I brought you Ukrainians so
you should ask Ukrainians was of zanies
restoration agreement and this agreement
is not just about Ukraine this agreement
is also about Europe because Putin has
been waging the hybrid war not only
against Ukraine in Ukraine it's about
delivering weaponry delivering regular
troops deliver ammunition every since
you don't bus in Europe is about paying
politicians paying journalists in trying
to hear exactly also you in Paris you
know from national weather they get any
kind of law from Russia it's a point
yeah I know that somehow and many people
know it and this official so it's about
changing the political landscape and
urine in Europe why and I'll tell you
it's about destroying the European Union
as we know it based on democracy rule of
law and solidarity and what Russia
really fears is the ladera tea and
because of that the whole station
agreement is not about any kind of
geopolitical constructions this
agreement is about the wheel of
Ukrainian people and because of that
there was masses of people staying at
the Maidan because of that regardless of
any you know differences the people have
been fighting for Ukraine for our
independence and for our choice to
decide what you do with our freedom and
not the Russian intentions you go
battery altar to divide the spheres of
influence so it's about sociation
agreement and my request look to you
also my personal request please come and
throat yes because you vote yes for you
create
you would here's four ingredients but
you will also vote yes for the European
Union and for democracy and human rights
the Dutch people we're at the beginning
of freedom in Europe how we understand
it and this freedom is something we
can't lose what canister